oh I want out of the sequel honestly
just two things invisible jet explicit
bondage themes they're right there in
the origins of the character Kahn
let's do it Wonder Woman 1984 yeah I
busted the bracers out so trailer has
dropped which doesn't mean huh
okay look doctor who normally would have
been a Sunday thing I've read jiggered
things things shifted around I didn't
have stuff in time I was gonna do it
Monday I forgot that Wonder Woman was
dropping so this is that things go back
to normal on Sunday again so this
trailer is a much better look we have
like little glimpses there have been
little little things here and there that
we've heard about this film up to this
point obviously the title is the year
that it takes place in so you know it's
gonna be a period piece we've known
about the cast and what roles they're
playing so there isn't a ton secretive
about this and there actually isn't a
lot of plot in this trailer it's mostly
vibe and feel and sort of getting a
taste of some of the characters and for
the most part I like most of what I see
I have some concerns but we'll come back
to those so obviously gal gadot really
his she is a phenomenal presence in this
world she is really really good for this
part that was that was stellar casting
they came up with I really like that the
that the color is much more vibrant in
general the whole thing feels more
colorful than a lot of the original
Wonder Woman film did but especially
like her outfit the Reds and the blues
really pop and I dig in the heck out of
that so that's very cool to see I'm
loving the way that the lasso is getting
used that makes me so happy because like
that
I'm not saying wonder when we can't have
a sword but like the sword is not her
iconic weapon the lasso is her iconic
weapon and I'm loving seeing so many
cool things being done like
using it to yank of something pull
herself so she's like propelled forward
and she's sort of whipping it around and
snapping at people for God's sake she
was swing-off lightning bolts with it
that's amazing that is so cool
loving that oh and she even took off the
tiara and whipped that around oh oh that
makes me happy that makes me very very
happy
we got our first glance of the woman who
will become the villain cheetah being
played by Kristen Wiig and she was fun
which if you know how much I kind of
inherently don't like Kristen Wiig
that's actually a really big compliment
for me to her cuz she grates on me quick
and and harshly so the little glimpses I
got here no seams sound so far seems
like she has some sort of established
relationship with Diana at the start of
things that presumably is gonna go sour
I've also got Pedro Pascal as as Maxwell
Lord boy
yeah he's you're really getting the the
vibe of this guy just thinks he runs
everything off Maxwell Lord and that's a
good fit and especially if we're talking
like 80 sort of tycoon ish he's a good
character to use if you're going for
that sort of feeling vibe the whole
1980s thing I'm a little I'm I'm not
negative on but I'm neutral on I think
on the one hand like I'm kind of over
eighties stahl juh right now because you
know we've had a couple of very hefty
doses of it in the last few years you
know we have now three seasons of
stranger things we had both it movies we
had Thor Ragnarok you know I I feel like
things either set in the 80s or
deliberately trying to evoke the 80s
vibe uh I don't want to say that fully
run their course but that in and of
itself isn't particularly novel to me at
this point that doesn't necessarily make
it a knock against the film I'm going to
be curious to watch it and see how it
justifies being set in the 80s
specifically it seemed pretty obvious
just for narrative purposes it was gonna
have to be set before and
other yeah any of them quote-unquote
modern-day stuff we've seen of
Wonderwoman be it BBS or or Justice
League but I do wonder if they're Connor
come up with a reason for it to be the
80s specifically as opposed to any other
time period beyond just you know the the
visual palette and the look of it which
again isn't a bad reason to set it in
that decade but it is kind of like it
yeah I've seen it quite a bit lately
actually
now that you mention it so there's one
character that is back and I this makes
me very nervous and that's Steve Trevor
now before I get into any of my
complaints and concerns
I should really point out that I was
phenomenally wrong about the original
Wonder Woman
I thought those trailers did not look
good at all and I called that that movie
was gonna stink and it didn't and it was
great I was so happy to be wrong as much
as I so often sort of zero in and like
predict what could go wrong I I do not
want to be right about that I'm not
someone who takes a lot of pleasure in I
told you so when instead of getting to
say I told you so I could have just had
something enjoyable I would much rather
have that so you know I I'm I've already
been proven a fool once for predicting
any kind of uh that might not work thing
with Wonder Woman so you know keep that
in mind so as far as Steve Trevor goes
how that works for me is probably gonna
really come down to how he comes back
but I'm still a bit irritated that it
does seem like however he's back he does
actually appear to be back
however logistically they figure out
that happening and I still I'm gonna say
it's gonna end up tying in to the to the
villains and she'll probably lose him
again at the end of it I mean maybe not
but like I don't this inherently kind of
undermines his sacrifice like it can't
help but do that just because he chose
to die and I really
great scene where like he's he's all
triumphing because he's got a little
plane it sort of sinks in on him that he
is going to die it was such a good scene
and now he's gonna be back
and again like maybe he's maybe it's not
like real or it's force by bit like who
knows what the circumstances are gonna
be and then that might help but like
just in general as much as I liked him
in the part and I loved their chemistry
I like the way they closed him out was
really good and really fitting and I
don't want to see that undercut just to
have the chemistry back so that's one
point of concern the other one this is
what's the point of a concern more of a
peace of wonderment to me which is that
she appears to be operating fairly
openly like she's at one point she's
dealing with the military convoy so okay
member that's not in public but the
military should know who she is
at one point it looks like she's in the
White House so the government should
definitely know where she is
and she's also in full outfit and doing
her thing
in the mall which would have you know
the general public and it just makes me
wonder if DC is just throwing up their
hands and completely abandoning any
pretense of continuity with either
Batman V Superman or Justice League both
of which pretty firmly established that
she was not known back after the events
of the original Wonder Woman that she
wasn't active she wasn't seen people
didn't realize that she was around doing
stuff and for her to be operating this
publicly I figure it's one of two things
either they're gonna have a really
contrived reason for why she still
somehow doesn't get you know noted down
and properly recorded or they're just
gonna go a heck with it and not address
it because at this point the continuity
of the DC films is completely and
utterly broken and that's not even
necessarily a complaint
on my part because I don't really care
if anything keeps in continuity with Man
of Steel or BBS or Justice League and I
actually even kind of enjoyed Justice
League but I don't I don't really care
if anything keeps in continuity with
those three films so I think it's
probably to the betterment of any
released film going forward that it very
if it's going to acknowledge continuity
at all it's very minor it's very tacitly
and - otherwise just forge its own
continuity for the most part and if it's
going to contradict something that was
in those earlier movies heck with it if
the story is good then just do it
and I suspect they're more likely to be
doing that then you know coming up with
something like the friggin men and black
neuralyzer to wipe everyone's memory and
account for why nobody knew who Wonder
Woman was at the start of Batman V
Superman I really hope they don't do
that cuz like I don't think they have to
like people like me will notice that
it's not in continuity but again I'll
notice but I also don't care so I figure
of the percentage of people who will
actually really massively notice at
which I'm calling as a minority of
movie-going audiences most maybe half of
them will actually care that it's not in
continuity so I don't think that's worth
trying to try to sort that out
but overall the music's really cool in
this - I dug that so overall I'm
definitely going into this feeling
better about it then with the original
Wonder Woman if for no other reason then
this has the track record of that first
Wonder Woman movie which I really
enjoyed and they brought back then you
know patty Jenkins Jenkins is by old
looks like we're gonna get more thigh
mascara that's cool I'm totally on board
for that there's a lot of neat images
and just watching gal gadot just do her
thing and this part it really is
inspiring like
just it's I'm in awe watching her just
be Wonder Woman she really does embody
this part about as well as Christopher
Reeves embodied Superman or Hugh Jackman
embodied Wolverine and Patrick Stewart
embodied Professor eggs it's just like
oh man like we may have to cast somebody
else in this role at some point but
that's it right there
pack up your bags is done that's
definitely the definitive screen version
she's really good for this and I think
I'll wrap it up on that few concerns few
questions but for the most part feeling
pretty good about this which is nice to
feel about a TC movie because even the
ones that I've enjoyed I've usually been
pretty skeptical of going in I actually
did enjoy Justice League I was very
skeptical of that going in
I enjoyed Aquaman was pretty skeptical
of that going in I enjoyed Wonder Woman
I thought it was gonna stink but it's
cannot remember the last time probably
not since the Dark Knight Rises have I
gone in to a a DC movie thinking based
off trailers I feel comfortable saying
this will be pretty good and that's nice
it's a good feeling
Wonder Woman 1984 full trailer what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down on the
comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do like subscribe support on
patreon consider it maybe share this
around and also there's links to all
sorts of stuff down below I have merch
I've got social media stuff I've got my
Peele box address if you feel like
sending me something for the holidays
hey you know why not is the season but
you don't have to do any of it folks cuz
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]